we're wrapping up our week-long series
and every intersection on our most
dangerous list charleston and rainbow
sahara decatur flamingo and pecos
flamingo boulder highway analysis they
all would be safer if we all took better
care whether we're behind the wheel or
on foot and off the surface streets
with the exceptions of no bus stops and
hopefully no pedestrians everything
we've talked about all week long is only
amplified when it comes to freeways
now technically where i-15 meets the 215
southern beltway is an intersection
freeway or surface street the director
of unlv's road equity project aaron
breen hears the frustration of southern
nevadans looking at themselves in
society's mirror anymore you know if
people don't go to court
they
don't have it reported to their
insurance company what lesson is if
there's no consequence so we've got to
go back to having consequences for
people who drive badly it needs to be a
community effort and it's a quality of
life issue
if you think it's a quality of life
issue speak up to the people that you
elect and tell them it's important to
you there you go aaron a little bit of a
soapbox there but you know what if most
of us are remembering to do better and
we can count on people who do worse
facing enforced consequences
maybe all intersections can become
less
dangerous i want to say thanks to aaron
bree for the great conversation metro
police with the crash statistics and
photojournalist matt adams for the cool
drone video that we had all week long
yeah you don't see those intersections
from up above very often no usually
gives you a great perspective of what we
have to navigate on some of our streets
yes and we need to keep that in mind we
were talking about whether you're on
foot or behind the wheel we can make our
intersection safer it's unfortunate that
we have to have consequences in order to
make people want to drive better right
you know we hear so much i get a lot of
emails are driving you crazy cars with
no plates cars with no tags and law
enforcement saying we just have too much
stuff we can't keep up with it so we're
talking to
maybe having the local elected leaders
tell the law enforcement here's what you
guys have to start enforcing